[Music]
welcome to the love planet today we are
counting down our picks for the 20 best
impressions in the past 50 years for
this Ness we are looking at the best
most memorable random or unexpected
impressions performed by comedians
without further ado let's get into this
Ross Marquand as Brad Pitt yeah so what
1,100 men went into the water three
hundred and sixteen men come out on the
sharks they took the rest June 29th 1945
and I want my shot every Spears doing
jay-z okay
jay-z how is it going with the twins the
new twins smell good you know I got Blue
Ivy you know I got my number sign so
it's all good Beyonce recently went to
Africa for vacation she loved it so I by
Billy Crystal as Sammy Davis jr. who can
take the British bring them to their
knees with passive resistance and some
curry if you please Big Daddy man Jay
mod does a great walking impression Wow
I'll jump and beat you to the punch
it's good that you here 101 ESPN st.
Louis sports station Joe Piscopo does
Frank Sinatra
[Music]
the jukebox baby
ah so as Jesse Ventura I was a Navy SEAL
I know you were you said I live in the
Baja all right I don't I I spent less
than six months a year in the
continental United States of America and
I have a thousand gallons of potable
water don't know what you're saying I
have a silo full of tortilla okay but
what is the point of what the what is
that well why don't you tell me Steve
Coogan does Michael Caine I'm not
prepared to do that all right all right
master Wayne Frank Gorshin do it Burt
Lancaster
let him again hey gosh Batman I wonder
what he's up to this time no need to
wonder boy wonder wonder wonder boy
I got the whole thing figured out to the
batpoles
I like going down the bat-pole Boy
Wonder
yeah me do Cape Crusader Oh golly gee
whiz I forgot to tell you when Alfred
who was cleaning up today
he accidentally spilled a bucket of glue
on one of the bad bulls
no kidding Robin I wonder which one it
was
[Music]
Kristin Drake turns into Liza Minnelli
Robby the healthy Eliza I just need to
find the clicker or the switch that
turns us all cuckoo thing down Rob big
Noddy impersonating Nicolas Cage you're
so sexy
[Music]
[Applause]
you smell so delicious
are already hungry on entering Chinese
place where where we can have duck or we
can go back into your apartment and just
so much then I'll kiss your face Oh
every Spears a Shack hi Jacques how are
you okay I see you doing a lot of
commercials these days you know
basketball my commercials but I've
always been around us husband Jay Mohr
impersonating Colin Quinn Jimmy
hodgepodge this is my new look a whole
hodgepodge and I'm wearing the sweater
and it's not Christmastime you a man of
people we got out of the coma yeah blue
collar guy smart Kuan as Kevin Spacey
Kevin Spacey Oh Kevin space sure sure I
wish I could say that I was surprised by
this but come on I mean who are you
gonna choose Matt Damon Bill Hader
impersonating James Carr with CF let me
start by saying I have nothing against
guns and I'm not just saying that
because I look like a bullet
I mean if this guy can walk out of a gun
store without answering some questions
something has gone wrong dance order
that's Randy Macho Man apparently the
whole Cogan thing is gonna get worst
yeah
keep some employment yeah just a little
bit racism in the big time yeah try to
run a little basketball game with him
yeah I'd be like hey ho let's do shirts
versus skins he'd seen against know me
that's that skins the wrong skin gym
mask you man as Woody Allen Moody
Allen's nothing you know iconic New York
voice it was reading recently in an
airline magazine excuse me you know if
the universe keeps expanding the way
it's going you know in a billion years
they're gonna have to add a hundred
thousand new area codes to the Manhattan
phonebook keeps me up at night
Frank Caliendo as John Madden I mean
you're in the Hall of Fame and you're
went to a new network and everything
how's all that going yeah I made a new
network I mean you wouldn't know about
switching Network stay but I mean this
is what I was thinking that you know you
go to a different place and you do
different things and still working
without Michaels of course the greatest
announcer in the world if you don't
count like 30 or 40 other guys to be the
same
[Music]
okay that's great working there and
great doing what we're doing there and
doing the things we do it as long as we
keep doing them I mean it's like the
Hokey Pokey put your right foot IDIA
take the right foot out you put your
right foot it is shake it all about you
do the Hokey Pokey and turn yourself
around Tommy smothers dead-on imitation
of Johnny Carson
[Applause]
it was so cold 42 degrees
at number two master impersonator rich
level as Richard Nixon
this is Richard how I love to be
President next I want to tell you you
know my fellow Americans I just got back
from Hollywood where I was working on a
new motion picture
it's called planet of the tapes at the
top of the list we have Josh Robert
Thompson do with Morgan Freeman he
sounds more like Morgan Freeman that
Morgan Freeman himself all that carpet
the way it goes from wall to wall just
doing what it does multiple colors and I
walk on you
sweet carpet you keep my feet patted
when they're bare oh I might stain you
from time to time but oh that's alright
you'll always be a carpet to me do you
agree with this list comment down below
what's your favorite hilarious
impression done by comedians for more
hilarious list be sure to subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]